actress singer mom entrepreneur it's no
wonder I got so many requests to talk
about the woman that John Mayer once
deemed his personal sexual Napalm if you
have reached the Jessica Simpson Hotline
in the late 90s she captured our
attention with a big voice and a
preacher's daughter type innocence kept
us addicted with her pop royalty wedding
and hit reality show solidified her role
as sex symbol in the Dukes of Hazzard
and has generated billions of dollars in
sales of shoes home decor clothing and
Chic pet beds but with her 2022 100
pound weight loss and subsequent
criticism suggesting that she had taken
it too far it feels like it's time to do
a deep dive so let's break down her diet
weight loss journey and Body Evolution
while attempting to eat like Jessica
Simpson for a day
art
now who's the employee of the month no
seriously it's supposed to be my first
day I just transferred from two three
two hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
back to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
before we dive into details of Jessica
Simpson's diet I want to take a moment
to emphasize that the meals I'll be
showcasing in this video are simply a
hypothetical reenactment based on the
meal plan that Jessica had reportedly
followed while we can certainly draw
inspiration from Jessica's approach for
nutrition and wellness it's important to
remember that everyone's body and
dietary needs are different what works
for one person may not work for another
and her diet certainly won't work
exactly for me so that's why I'm using
as a teachable moment for gentle
nutrition and how to Showcase how to
build balanced healthy meals please keep
in mind that this video should not be
used as a guide for what you should eat
every day and if you're new here don't
forget to subscribe to the channel ring
that Bell so you never miss out and
follow me on Instagram and Tick Tock at
Abby's kitchen folks if you like sleep
you need to listen to a girl who has
spent years chasing a good night's rest
AIDS sleep has completely changed the
game I got so much great feedback from
the last time I mentioned this so
clearly a lot of you guys feel the same
this is eight sleeps pod cover and it's
finally transformed my bed into the
perfect sleeping conditions for me I run
very hot especially at night while my
husband is always complaining that it's
too cold and the Pod cover allows us to
set the temperature of our bed between
55 and 110 Fahrenheit on each side so
you can both live your best sleepy time
life and it's not just about better
Comfort there's actual science to back
this up so research suggests that we
fall asleep best when the temperature
drops between 1 and 3 degrees Fahrenheit
and then when we need to wake up the
temperature should gradually climb the
Pod monitors your body temperature and
then adjusts it up and down to keep you
in the optimal zone for your bed
preferences and environment it also
tracks and collects data while you sleep
without you having to wear any kind of
uncomfortable wearable device this is
really helpful for folks who are
training because you can see how your
sleep affects your recovery it also
replaces the blaring alarm in the
morning with like a gentle chest level
vibration and a gradual increase in
temperature which helps you naturally
wake up without the unpleasant shock to
the system I fully realize that this is
a higher ticket item but I've also come
to realize over the past few years of
struggling with my sleep that you just
cannot put a price on really good
quality sleep we have ample evidence
that sleep is one of the most important
modifiable factors contributing to our
health Mental Health weight management
Stress Management immunity cognitive
Health chronic disease risk and more and
their numbers really speak for
themselves pod sleepers have been shown
to fall asleep 44 faster and get into 34
percent deeper sleep it has been
life-changing for someone like me so if
you want to try out the Pod cover for
yourself check out the link in my
description and use my promo code Abby
to get 150 off of your order so in a
2022 Instagram post Jessica showed off
her toned body with the caption I have
gained and lost a hundred pounds three
times so I never thought this moment
could or would happen but I am finally
spring breaking wearing a bikini hard
work determination self-love I enjoyed a
good proud cry today six months later
she launched a tick tock ad for Pottery
Barn which had the entire internet
worried she had taken it too far I
reacted to the video right here and
while a lot of the concern online was
around drugs alcohol and mental health a
number of the comments and reaction
videos actually just expressed concern
about her body and weight ultimately if
you're a regular viewer here you know
that I never comment on creators or
celebrities bodies I only comment on
problematic behaviors and advice which
may or may not be related to said body
we don't know what's going on behind the
scenes when someone loses or gains
weight and our commentary on this may
Ashley serve to perpetuate some of these
intern journal or mental health
struggles I can tell you that when I was
struggling with disorder eating feeling
like everyone was talking about my
shrinking body only made me want to
retreat further which just perpetuated
the mental health struggles that
perpetuated the problematic behaviors
and let's just imagine hypothetically
that Jessica is in a similar boat what
it really surprised you given the gross
body shaming she's been subjected to all
of her career look at her ass now it
looks like Jess is enjoying a whole lot
of southern cooking like the woman
really can't win so let's not tear women
down for their bodies wherever they land
on the Spectrum if we're gonna break
anything down today folks it's gonna be
diet culture
that was a lot before coffee so Abby get
at me so Jessica apparently credits her
recent weight loss to Harley pasternak's
body Reset Program you probably
recognize the name Harley Pasternak from
my Megan Fox video because she credits
her body to one of his other programs
the five Factor diet but back to the
body reset listen to Harley's elevator
pitch I'm going to give you a healthy
safe alternative to a rapid weight loss
program okay in five days you're going
to transform your body and learn to keep
it off for the next 10. I'm sorry did we
just say keep it off for 10 days is that
supposed to be a strong marker of
success Abby help so according to
Harley's book The Body reset die is a
celebrity endorsed 15-day diet for the
first five days you're just drinking
smoothies and having two low-calorie
snacks per day plus walking a minimum of
a thousand steps and doing five to ten
minute bouts of strength training
throughout the day in phase two you swap
in one low calorie meal either a salad
Soup Sandwich stir-fry or egg white
scramble and in phase three you get two
of these low calorie meals the total
daily calories clock in around 1200 to
1400 calories per day so yeah not
surprisingly people do lose weight
according to Harley you're more likely
to stick to a weight loss program when
you see rapid weight loss at the start
and this is actually evidence-based
research suggests that you're more
likely to stay motivated when you see an
immediate drop on the scale surprising
not so much the other benefit of the
program is that it's high in fiber and
we know that diets rich in fiber are
associated with better weight management
but guess what happens when the 15 days
of hanger are up
you're probably going to go back to
business as usual and gain the weight
right back I'm not sure I ever
understand the point of pulling the rain
so tight that you can't help but just
like completely throw in the towel and
Harley actually is a very well educated
smart guy like he knows this is not the
ideal he even stated in his interview
that he's traveled around the world
promoting slow sustainable weight loss
but that's not the message most people
want to hear okay look tell you what if
you can't beat him join him I mean I
agree that we do have to meet people
where there are and some people want a
crash diet and we really can't change
their mind but still this probably is
not a diet that I would professionally
indoors
yeah there has never been a 15 day 1200
calorie diet that I can get behind but
what I can get behind is coffee and
according to the list of foods that are
on the Nay and yay list for Harley I
cannot my coffee as long as what I put
in it is not actually sweetened with
sugar yay so I've got an unsweetened
latte here I have this nut pods oat
creamer which I'm obsessed with it is
unsweetened says so right here and it's
got no sugar but it just adds just like
a little bit of creamy flavor which is
all that I want because I really do not
like sweet coffee you guys know that so
that's just a titch that's all I'm gonna
do
now Harley does allow for non-dairy milk
and fat-free milk which feels like
pretty archaic knowing what we know now
about Dairy fats but Abby can you
elaborate yeah the 80s have called and
they wanted skim milk back I'm bringing
skim milk
the question of whether or not saturated
fat is truly bad for your health is
still being debated though as I
discussed in my video right here most of
the updated research suggests that it's
really not a big deal but dairy fat
specifically has a lot of unique
benefits research has Associated intake
of full fat Dairy with a reduced risk of
obesity in adults and in children and
this may be due to this a tidy program
of higher fat foods and or the unique
properties of the short chain fatty
acids found in Dairy thank you Abby I
just needed a little caffeine to get me
through this first leg in the morning
and speaking of dairy fat let's start
our day with one of Harley's recommended
Greek yogurt-based smoothies which is
pretty much a staple of the body reset
plan oh even the name kind of makes me
cringe but let's see so according to
Harley here if you're gonna make a meal
out of a smoothie as you have to on this
diet you've got to make sure that it's
nutrient packed and balanced with sea
treating ingredients protein yes fiber
and healthy fat yes Harley we love to
see it he's obviously talking about my
Hunger crushing combo because it
actually does work so this right here I
can get behind what I can't get behind
here folks is having a smoothie for a
meal three times a day or limiting my
calories to like 1200. that is what my
toddler eats folks
so we're gonna skip right to phase three
of this plan where I only have to have
one smoothie today and I'm going to show
you how we make it we got a banana
bananas don't have a lot of fiber it is
true but they add a lot of flavor and I
feel like this recipe is going to need
it so I've got a pear that has come into
contact with a small child we will just
remove the evidence
to pop that in because pairs are one of
the greatest sources of fiber out there
if you can't poop have a pear it's a
great rule of thumb pears make you poop
pears make you poop just just remember
that I have got an avocado here for my
healthy fats just like a nice perfect
size for it too look at that look at
this beaut oh I'm killing it today the
sun is shining I'm like just feeling it
oh that's a good sign that's a good omen
right there folks all right you can just
squish it in
Sans pit
that's going to add our healthy fats
plus a lot more fiber good for the gut
I've got the last of my kale here for
some veggies
nice
Greek yogurt and as we've already
established your girl doesn't do fat
free for many many reasons but mainly
that I just
can't get into the taste and consistency
so this is a five percent Greek yogurt
right here much more delish
and then some pea based milk
this is going to add a little bit more
protein too much more so than like basic
almond milk let's blend
moments later I'm gonna lose two pounds
just from sucking so hard
what
oh
that's better
this is very very good banana is key it
helps to bring on the sweetness but the
pear brings the fiber we got healthy
fats in our avocado and of course
protein in the milk and the Greek yogurt
I like a good thick smoothie because
that way it just like feels more like a
meal in my belly rather than these like
thin watery protein shakes that's not a
meal that's just protein so
this this is going to be satisfying
so let's talk exercise on Harley's body
Reset Program now first of all it's
important to note that Harley is a
personal trainer he's not a registered
dietitian and on this plant specifically
he recommends getting in a minimum of 10
000 steps a day plus doing some sporadic
five to ten bouts of strength training
so it's not to supercharge the appetite
while still burning calories I don't
wear an activity tracker for reasons
that I discussed right here I want to
tell you a little bit of a story on how
my Fitbit actually kind of made me less
fit but I could totally go for a walk it
is gorgeous outside poppy it's your time
to shine come on girl
yeah when it comes to exercise and
appetite the literature tends to
demonstrate a j-shaped curve basically
low levels of physical activity lead to
dysregulated hunger where we see a
mismatch between appetite and energy
expenditure that is we tend to consume
more calories than we burn
[Music]
but when we go from low to medium or
even high levels of activity our
appetite and calorie intake actually
Decline and more accurately matches our
energy expenditure super high activity
levels AKA more than 840 minutes of
exercise per week or the equivalent of
burning over 3 500 calories in a week in
intentional exercise is associated with
higher appetite so it is true that
Harley's program is likely not going to
reach anywhere near the hunger boosting
threshold that said there's really no
evidence that breaking up your activity
into five or ten minute bouts instead of
one larger or longer session will have
any measurable impact on appetite any
activity is good activity and will
ultimately contribute to your daily
caloric expenditure so find a routine
that works for you and stick to it
okay well now that I smell better let's
make some lunch let's take a little
look-see through the body reset meal
plan for some meal inspiration brought
To Us by the letter s
[Music]
okay so according to phase three of
Harley's program we get to choose from
soup salad sandwich stir fry or a
scramble AKA an egg white scramble I'm
hungry after just having a
smoothie for breakfast I don't liquid
meals doesn't matter how many calories I
pack in they just do not hold me for
very long so I feel like my favorite
meal of the day just like got skipped
AKA breakfast so we're gonna do a
scramble and call that our lunch so
Harley's directions for making a
scramble say that you need to include
veggies high fiber carbs low-fat cheese
and only use egg whites Abby I know we
covered the like low-fat high fat Dairy
blender but can we go over egg whites
versus the whole egg yeah throwing away
all the yolks is like ripping the tag
off your collector's beanie baby that is
like straight straight up sacrilege I'm
still holding on to princess dye and
platy for my retirement fund yes you're
going to make me so much money one day
we used to think that egg yolks were bad
for your health because they are rich in
dietary cholesterol but we now know that
dietary cholesterol doesn't really have
any major impact on blood cholesterol
levels if we look at the whole versus
white debate in the context of weight
loss which is what this diet is about I
do understand the approach but I also
think it is kind of short-sighted an
average egg white has about 16 calories
compared to the yolks which have 54
calories with virtually no fat in the
white compared to 4.5 grams in the yolk
that said we're looking at almost the
same amount of protein per part of the
egg and most of the eggs nutrition is
housed in the yolk yolks are rich in
choline iron B12 plus vitamins a d e and
K all of which actually need some fat to
be absorbed there are actually so many
studies on egg-based meals associated
with weight loss likely because the
unique combination of protein and fat
that's helped suppress our hunger
hormones a super low fat diet is
ultimately very hard to sustain because
it lacks both the satiety and the
satisfaction Factor so my general tip
for folks who are trying to maintain a
caloric deficit and focus on protein
while still reaping the benefits of egg
yolks is to do one whole egg plus one or
two extra whites mixed in
love that idea Abby so I'm gonna do two
whole eggs plus two egg whites and
that'll bring me just over 20 grams of
protein
take one
egg two
I'm gonna have some egg whites here so
two tablespoons so like a quarter cup
to do salt pepper and
some nooch
to give some more cheesy flavor and more
protein plus B12 we love that
all right looking down I'm looking down
looking good let's go down
[Applause]
[Music]
and I got little pieces of random
vegetables in my fridge so we got corn
which I just started putting corn in my
eggs and guys it is next level good like
my favorite eggs are now with corn it
just adds like a little hint of
sweetness I got some broccoli I've got
some cooked carrots
and I've got the very much not fat free
cheese because we do not buy fat-free
cheese in my house
no we don't and we won't all right I
gotta scramble this before it just
becomes a crepe
oh while that's happening I think we'll
throw some sourdough bread into the
toaster
for some healthy carbs and fiber
the curry ketchup is like my new
favorite Obsession on eggs
it just hits different um
let's talk snack so the snack options
for Harley's diet here read literally
like any early 2000s tabloid magazine
celebrity diet plan like these
celebrities probably pay a fortune for
any kind of like Fitness or nutrition
advice so I can't not just put like a
little more effort or creativity into
the snacks anyways all the snacks have
to be under 150 calories and include
edamame air popped popcorn whole grain
crackers and fat free cheese
no celery with peanut butter she's
pissed about the fat-free cheese too
she's like
hell to the no mama or apple slices with
deli turkey not a lot to work with here
folks I'm gonna go with the edamame
because it's easy and I like it and I
feel like we can make it a lot more fun
all right so I literally just put Frozen
edamame in the microwave for like two
minutes until it's thawed through and
hot this is how you take it to the next
level Mike's hot honey we put this on
everything I put that on everything
as we've established lots of sesame
seeds for those healthy fats oh yeah
and of course
fancy
salt
we'll do a little salt by action
and that's how you know it's done that
is how you know it's celebrity Worthy
I feel like these just make it harder
we're all about the fingers in here look
at that and honestly edamame is such a
delicious hunger crushing combo we've
got fiber we got protein we got healthy
fats in the Sesame here plus some little
sticky spicy sweet hot honey on top
oh my God
there's no need to eat edamame any other
way poppy this will not feel so good
coming out the other side
we are not going to risk it because I do
not want a veterinarian bill
it is dinner time and your girl is super
hungry so I guess it's back to S Club 5
when it comes to meal selections
[Music]
I feel like of the 5S options soup salad
sandwich scramble and stir fry stir fry
is the most obvious option which works
for me because you can kind of make a
stir fry without ever the you have
in the fridge and that is actually
totally my way of cooking I have some
leftover rice in the fridge which is
great because it's going to save me a
lot of time but also leftover rice has
some unique properties over fresh Abby
you want to go over this for us yeah
this is gonna sound like a tick tock
urban legend but you can actually reduce
the glycemic index of rice and lower its
absorbable calories simply by putting it
in the fridge to cool overnight to try
to put this very simply it comes down to
the science of retrogradation starch and
rice is made up of two molecules amylose
and amylopectin when rice is cooked
amlopectin molecules absorb water and
swell but as it cools hydrogen bonds
develop between amylose molecule tools
transforming the starch into something
called resistant starch resistant starch
is more resistant to absorption in the
gut so it lowers the glycemic response
and the amount of carbs that we can
actually utilize in that food as a
result retrogradation can reduce the
glycemic response improve gut health by
increasing Prebiotic fiber and possibly
even reduce the total calories in that
meal research presented in 2015
experimented with a variety of different
techniques and found that adding a small
amount of coconut oil while cooking
about three percent by weight could
possibly enhance the glycemic lowering
effect because the fat makes the starch
granules resistant to enzymes that would
normally break down the starch the
researchers found that cooling lower
starch Rices resulted in a reduction in
absorbable calories by about 10 to 15
percent but they believe that higher
starch Rices could be reduced by up to
50 or 60 percent I mean I certainly
would never recommend purple Fleet
cooking rice and not eating it fresh
just to potentially save some calories
but hey if it helps with blood sugar
management and also helps to contribute
to our gut health I think it's a totally
fine reason not to toss your leftover
rice love this journey for us because
while fresh rice of course is so much
more fluffy day old rice actually is
better for like a fried rice stir-fry
situation because it actually
caramelizes a lot easier just a heads up
though if you are reheating day old rice
that's been in the fridge you have to
make sure that it's fully steaming and
heated all the way through to reduce the
risk of foodborne illness so because
this diet is less than inspired I'm
gonna try to upgrade it just a little
bit with some kind of a flavorful sauce
we're gonna do a peanut sauce and I'm
just going to kind of freestyle here
just based on what I have and what I
know I like peanut sauce starts with
peanuts I like using the crunchy but
really it doesn't really matter we're
gonna add some soy sauce
I'm not measuring don't ask me the
measurements I just kind of do it until
I taste it and I taste what I like a
little rice wine vinegar this is the
seasoned rice wine vinegar
and then basically I'm just trying to
like hit all the flavors like sweet
salty Savory spicy nutty that
might be spicy we're gonna see how it
goes okay and then some coconut milk is
like our base
that's a little thick like peanut butter
whipped cream oh
um it is really delicious okay a little
more coconut water just to thin it out
and more soy
for this
all right okay I think I think that's
the magic combo I just know I just know
yes okay so I'm using extra lean ground
chicken but obviously you could use
whatever kind of protein you like if you
want to do tofu if you want to do shrimp
if you want to do fish whatever is your
style or what you have on hand
foreign
just stomping on
ground meat this is always the most
unesthetic part of a food demo the raw
meat part okay now that started I
figured this is a good time to use up
these like little bits of frozen veg
that I have in my freezer everyone harps
on frozen veg but the reality is that a
lot of times this is actually more
nutritious because Frozen fruits and
vegetables are flash frozen so they lock
in a lot of those nutrients plus it's
just a convenient way to get in your
produce and you don't have to go ahead
and buy like five different vegetables
to make your stir fry so this is a big
Plus for me
I've also got some frozen edamame so I'm
going to throw that in too let that all
heat through
we've always got rice in the house
literally always might as well pop that
in
and I know we've got a sauce going on
but I do like to still give the stir fry
a good amount of seasoning to begin with
so I'm adding lots of sesame seeds so
that they kind of like toast up in the
pan then I'm gonna do a little bit of
soy sauce
a touch of sesame oil
I like a little honey
just to balance out the Umami and
saltiness of the soy or Tamari
and the peanut sauce
so I'm not gonna lie this has probably
been one of the most boring Bland and
banal days that I have encountered
during this series and as we've
established the list of approved snacks
definitely leave something to be desired
air popped popcorn is on the list and
you guys know I love my popcorn but they
don't allow any kind of butter or fat or
flavoring on it which is like
me and also I just sometimes need a
little some sweet before bed and an
apple with turkey slices
probably not gonna cut it so I'm gonna
do my favorite air popcorn which does
have some fat in it sorry Harley
breaking the rules here and I'm gonna
throw in some birthday cake cookies as a
nod to Jessica Simpsons now defunct
Beauty brand dessert if you know you
know I don't love the name of the brand
but I love their popcorn it is
so good so buttery and yet there's
actually no butter it's I think coconut
oil and Himalayan pink sea salt I don't
care because it is the best popcorn of
life does anybody remember that line
like it was described as the first
lickable and tastable and kissable
Beauty line I don't know it's kind of
gross to me that a beauty line marketed
solely to young girls had product titles
like Tria my papaya what and deliciously
kissable hot body topping I mean I'm not
a prude but sounds like something you
should be getting at a sex shop not at
Sephora also I'd rather eat dessert than
lick sticky body lotion off my hands
maybe I'm the only one let me know in
the comments below your thoughts but
anyways I feel like there's probably a
reason that it got discontinued also
plain no butter no salt no fat air
pop popcorn like those days are long
gone for me well folks I can't say that
this was the most inspired day of eating
in fact it was boring but I did my best
to abify it to break the rules that I
believe needed to be broken and add a
little flavor and fun where I can I
don't see any issue with replacing one
meal a day with a nice hearty
well-balanced smoothie I think that
makes sense but what doesn't make sense
is to limit yourself to five types of
meals that start with the letter s or
1200 calories a day and most importantly
it doesn't make sense to follow a diet
for 10 to 15 days when you know you're
gonna gain that weight right back and on
that note that's all that I have for you
guys today if you liked it be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on Whose diet you love me to try
next and your thoughts on this whole
body Reset Program don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
little bell so you never miss out and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye bye